Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Stowaway.
Now this game first came out in 2014.
Actually this is a demo that was released alongside a kick starter that unfortunately didn't get funded
And i hadn't heard about this game until just now, but there is a fully functional alpha
which is what you're seeing right now.
(Reads) Navigate to the other side of D Deck, - find a flashlight, - find a toolbox, - regulate the valve pressure
- Use the CCTV Feed to view the rooms ahead
- Pay close attention to the deck signs to help you navigate
- read notes for information relevant to your area
So what's interesting about this, is that I played another game that was alike this
where you were on a boat that you weren't supposed to be on
and you were trying desperately to get off the boat.
Now I can't remember what the name of it is because I'm very bad with --- (CCTV feed beeps)
What is that?
I see a shimmerin' shadow over there!
That better be a heavy blanket blastin' in the winds!
And oh my god!
The frame rate is very low.
eeEEEee
But why?
It IS a blanket blowin' in the winds...
OK, Imma be right back, i'm going to change some settings a bit
Okay and we're back
And I don't know if this is going to be running any smoother now -
Oh, I can zoom in quite a lot -
But there is
A device... sOMEWHERE
HERE
there we go
wait no that's not it...
use the CCTV, ahhhhhh pay close attention to the deck signs
OK they're going to help me navigate
I'm still gonna be LOST
I dont even know if it's the right ---
Oooooh
(CCTV beeps) Aaaaaah
Tab to view the- OOOH
That's cool!!
COOOOOOOL!!
WOAHHHHH
That's neat-o.
Kay, what's this?
Do I have another note in my hand?
I can't read it. There's not enough light
man that's such a weird concept
that I have to get ambient light to be able to look at this
- CCTV has minimal range
- One lighter, low fuel
- Two batteries, need a flashlight
- supplies and resources are limited. Use sparingly
- follow signs, find path to the other side of deck A
COOOOOL!!!
Well I can't go down there, it's been all bashed up
I hope to stop a monster
and apparently there is some sort of a quarantine around here
oh jeez
oh
Oh jeez!
I don't have a flashlight!
Oh gash!
Oh Gersh!
(Ship creaks)
Don't mind that
The ship's just fartin'!
Alright let's just drop down why not-
because I feel like it
So apparently as is the namesake of the game
you are a stowaway
on a ship
and I don't know why you decided to stow away on this particular ship that probably has a ---
(beeping sounds as tv turns on)
Ay!
Hey I was talkin' thare!
alright fine you
alright, what else do we got
let me read by the light of this horrifying TV
(Reading note) "I saw the Doc escort someone onboard today while i was cleaning the deck."
That's three people he's brought on board now that I've seen at least
"Haven't seen the other 2 in a while, wonder if they're still here..."
Oh THEY'RE STILL HERE ALRIGHT
they've just been mutated into a horrible monstrosity.
Man, I am sad that I got to this game...
woah
Turn handle?
I didn't even know there was a handle there!!
I couldn't see a god damn thing
mouse up
wait
aoohhh
ohhh ok
so let me check my
oh there's nothing here
well
well that's not good
turn handle-- No, not that.
I'm not, I'm not looking for that right now
man!
I mean it looks dang good
i just wish it would
oooohhhhhh
that's creepy
oh that's creepy
(loud bang and noises)
(incoherent words)
was that something up there??
i wasn't looking at it
I was too busy looking at how cool my lighter was
Okay, so I need to go to the D Deck
but there was something down here
oooh peek and lean
bob and weave!!
man, I'm sad that this kick starter didn't go through
would've been a great game
one of the... one of them has escaped
one of THEM.
great.
god dammit there's a light here, but i can't
ugh
jeez gotta catch
what happened?
(loud creaking noises)
MY LIGHTER JUST WENT OUT
ooohh dat ain't good.
oooh dat's one of them not good things.
I can barely read this
(gasp) Hi! hello... hi friend... how are you doing?!
Are you going to start bobbing your head around like R-E-seventy-seven (RE77)?
well who's there?!
euh it's no one
ok...
Alright, so that's how this game's going to be, huh?
alright
(Reading) "One of them has escaped, I barricaded what remains of the door to protect the rest of the deck, not sure how long it'll last for."
"I'm going to head down to B Deck, that guy in the diner suit - DIVER'S SUIT seems to... hunt in the upper decks...
...it'll be safer."
"I was sure i left my flashlight down there"
you mean down here? where I is?
I don't want to go down there
holy shit
everything about that stairwell screams that i'm going to die
alright let's go for it
What the- my lighter's out of fuel?
I stupidly let it run while i was watching it, how it ---
(gasp)
oh i thought that was eyes
oh i thought it was eyes
i thought that was eyes
ooh
that - that, that - that's a li - that's a little weird
tha - that's weir-- is that THIS room?
ohhgggh
(Door creaks) HEYYYY!!!
HI!
ok
oh
sh-should I be - should I be concerned about the breathing?
uuhh
(door slams)
heyyyy ok
they want some privacy
they thought that i was another person
someone for an intimate encounter
on a deserted ship
but that ain't me
oh is that a flashlight?
that better be a flashlight
little shit
yes!
flashlight, 2
oh cool!
ughhhh
elewww!
euuugh!
uuuugh that ain't good
the engine room hath doth been blasted
oh boy
and now i get to go back here
ok can i run? i can run a little bit
it's more of a spr-----
(Pipe breaks loudly) AIEEeeeee-kay.
didn't scare me
didn't scare me at all.
I'm not scared by steam as - as is evident from other horror games that I've played in the past
steam does not bother me
doesnt bother me none
oh this is open now? oh wait this was open before..
show last note
why do i need to read the last note?
i mean these are all very useful tutorials for my everyday life, but..
i'm not 100% sure ---
(loud bang)
ok
(Smacks lips)
alrighty then
(Tense string music)
hii!!!
hello!
are you being...
are you being chased by an entire orchestra?!
uh oh, they're plucking the strings now
what was that?
yea this game looks good, but it doesn't run a hundred percent well
obviously it's an early access, so..
uh er it's an early demo, so it's not the full
what to expect out of the game i imagine
ok ehhh
ok EHHH
alright that worked.
what is with THAT
why is that still on my feed?
(three loud bangs)
oosshhggahh ohhh god
god dammit don't look at the god damn door
(CCTV device beeps multiple times)
what's happening?
ok so there's a tool box in there
is that supposed to help me?
i don't understand
what you're
kerfuddlin' about (CCTV beeps again)
oh hello
did that change
oh god i have no idea
ok, last note, N.
thankfully it taught me that
turn this off
(Reading) "Those damn vents upstairs, always getting clogged!! If I have to crawl through them one more time..."
"Remember to repair the vent cover at the top of D Deck stairs by the storage room"
oh
so there's a vent
that I can go through
is what you're saying
I got more lighter fuel, which is a good thing i guess.
so there's a vent somewhere around here
that I'm gonna be able to crawl through
"CCTV Monitoring"
so that's this room?
(dull clattering noises)
ohhhh someone is ALREADY IN the VENTS....
what is that
oh, oh that's another
ugh guh im out of batteries?!
ALREADY?!
HOW?!
jeezums, at least i got another lighter
I gotta stop wasting that
but I have no indication meter of when it's going to be out
can I open these? nope.
just glues right to the door, no matter where i'm looking.. OK
so this is the toolbox
that i saw on my CC---
(metallic noise)
ok that's good, I guess?!
I dont know?!
I guess it's good!
(porthole squeaks open)
(wind whistling)
(porthole shuts)
oh, ok.
so--
(porthole squeaks)
(wind whistling)
(porthole shuts)
mmmmmmmmm
mmmm!
that sure is a ---
(Loud metallic clank)
Heyyyyyyyyy
didn't scare me
didn't scare me at all....ok
so D Deck
wait, storage?
ohh it blasted off of that
oh shit
alright well i guess ill go up here then
oh this is spoopy
don't mind me
don't mind me pooping my pants...
but I'm pretty sure this is the entrance to the thing
but I dont have enough
I don't have enough ANYTHING to be able to crawl all the way through here
without being accosted by something
ohh there it goes
now I'm in complete darkness!
how am I supposed to be able to --- nooo ...
what's that?
what am I looking at?
where's up? I can barely see
but --- AHHHH there we go
woahhhheyyyy don't run from me!
don't run!
don't run, i am trying to help!
unless I am the monster
ok
now that we got to someplace where we can actually see
man, I swear..
oh that's a bad sign
ok
woom, did I fall?
can't really tell
oh
what's happenin'?
something's happenin'.
can't see anything
I'm out of flashlight and LIGHTER
ok there i go
ah ha!
I knew it!
ok
so is there anything else over here that I need?
what is this?
BATTERIES!
Thank you! Gimme those
ok
so I'm going to be very sparing with this
and only when i need it!
not immediately, only when I need it!
can I go down there?
oh boy
ok so where did that guy run through?
oh is this his bloo- (Distant but loud creak) ohh ---
is this his blood?
an ---
(loud growling/roaring)
"Don't let him out"
well I mean it'd crossed my mind
maybe the possibility of giving him unquestionable freedom
(Reads) "The pressure's too damn high, one of these days it's going to blow!"
"I wonder how long this valve will regulate the pressure"
"Captain won't listen, oh well, not my problem"
(loud growling/roaring continues)
What is uhh...
What's, uh - what's making the ruckus?
is this going to blow... when I twist it?
(air hissing)
It might blow
oh that sounds like it's going to blow
woah, hello
holy shit
hi
are you waving to me?
ok
Probably shouldn't have stopped for that
is it going to blow?
probably not
dammit there's gotta be something else to be done about this, right?
no
no that's it.
I'm twisting my mouse every which way
so I dont think that's it
there's gotta be something else
oh
no that's just the same thing it was showing before
oh jeez
I guess there was another way that i could go over here
down here?
welp, down seems good
down seems real good
oh boy
thank you for all the tutorials
I mean they honestly are very helpful
I just gotta figure out what im supposed to be doing
oh hello
more lighter, yes!
ohhh this looks
dark
that's not helpful at all
ok
(Under breath) I can't see anything
hello
ehhhh
ehhhhhh
is that something?
nah, it's just a slot for pooping
what does that say?
(whooshing noises)
AHHHHHHHHHHHH SHE'S BEHIND ME!!
THAT'S WHAT IT SAYS! ITS SAYS SHE'S BEHIND ME!
rrraaaAAAHHH!
(slam)
oooook
I apologize for what was probably one of my girliest screams
I thought she was right up my butt
whoever SHE was
I- I should have held myself a little better together
I apologize
(CCTV beeping)
did I get new?
what is that?
a lounge area?
"She's watching you"
is she now??
uh huhhhhh
well
does she like what she sees?
probably not
can't go through there
(CCTV beeps) I can go further down though
thats always a good sign
well that's the same thing
(Breathy noise)
who's there?
I'll just take these. thank you.
spare everything. But I don't even know if they're going to help
can I open this?
(CCTV beeps) no I cannot.
OK going back up
wooo (CCTV beeps) alrighty then
Don't know why that keeps happening like that
oh, this is ominous
did I come this way, or am I going this way?
I -- I can't quite tell
eh
uh oh!
ah shit
dead end
god dammit
nothing over here
ok
eeek
ohhhhh good and foggy
good and foggy
ah there's nothing here
just a bunch of dead ends!
cause I can't go down that way to the right
so I gotta go back up I-apparently
I-parently
ok
soooo ohhhhhhh
that looks important
OK! but now which one does this go to?
I'm not 100% sure it wasn't very obvious which one goes where
ok
(door creaks open)
is that a bad thing?
should I go down that way?
HEYYY OK you're - why? What is that?
what is it --- what is that like a...
A Mongol... outfit?
I have no idea
so weird
ok
so im gonna--- hang on---
is that the...?
this might be the CCTV area
ahhh it totally is. OK
So why was this being monitored?
and why is she watching me?
good questions
(Reading) "The Diver is toying with me, he opened all the doors to the Med Bay and let them ALL out..."
"He removed the handle from the D Deck doors, leaving me to fend for myself."
"I found a spare handle in one of the locker rooms, when I get my strength back, I'll make a break for it..."
well. K.
It seems like ya didn't make it
you're not OK after all
ok
k, so straight down this way
at the end of the hall
should be where I was supposed to go
right?
shit
did that just run out?
no
ok
I just got --
OK there we go
I was about to say
I JUST got batteries.
wait a minute
have I been here before?
I already know about the lighter, but...
what?
wait a minute
did it-- did it send me in a big circle?
I mean, I'd be totally fine if it did, but..
ohhhhh ok
soo AHHHH here??
YES!
OPEN!
What the fuck was that all about?
that was weird
ok
it opened instantaneously
did I make it?
oh shit
more over here
ok
well this doesn't seem like an exit..
kinda just seems like more death..
shit
oh, shit, I can't see anything in here
oehehh
THAT'S NOT GOOD!
OH! I thought that was a pile of bodies at first
OK
oh jeez
oh jeez scoob
oh jeeze i cant read this
it's too dark
"A"
What does "A" mean?
Do I get a - gold star?
did I win?
Did I win?
I probably won
that's probably what this means
I did so good
(footsteps)
THAT WAS NOT ME
those foot step-y steps were not me
K so thats blocked off.
ok
alrighty then
oohhh ok
can I go that way?
ah there's nothing to do that way
OK, only one way
here we go!
I gues---
(spooky noises and CCTV beep)
what does that mean?
OH! its back to that one then
oh good!
I was hoping to see the weird shadow
(door squeaks) AHHHH!
dont do that.
(moans)
AHH FUCK HE'S BEHIND ME
OK I THOUGHT THAT (semi-coherently) WAS NOT GOING TO BE A THING
OHHHHHHHHHHH
AHHHHHHHHHH
JUMP!
I'm stuck!
oh
awwwww
ahhhhhh
ahhh that was soo good!
dang it!
ah that was so good!
OK
so I think that's all
for that one
ii- it is - it's a dang shame
that the game wasn't funded on Kickstarter
that was a really well made demo
that was really interesting and scary
and- I mean, it wasn't optimized perfectly
obviously.
because it didnt run quite well
but even so...
it was a good proof of concept
it could have been turned into something way bigger and better
I think what the slow down was
just because the whole ship was in one level
and you were just wandering through the same place
it was a lot for the computer to load
but either way
thats really good
I hope there's still some lingering light
left in this project
because it could be turned into something really cool
soo, I don't know,
I'll link to the developers website
and all that stuff
So you can find out for yourselves
But I really like this game
and I'm really sad that I didn't get to it sooner
so
Thank you everybody so much for watching
send the developers some love
in whatever way you can
and as always
i will see YOU
in the next video
BYEE BYEEE!!